Speaker 1: So yesterday I talked about the
death of Colin Powell, and we talked about
the political side of it.
Colin Powell, a Republican who yes, in his
later years spoke out against anti-Muslim
rhetoric and condemned the xenophobia and
the nonsense of Donald Trump and Trump's followers,
was not a Trump supporting Republican, but
also was one of the most sinister figures
in the sale of the Iraq War to the American
people in the international community with
faulty intelligence back in 2003.
And we looked at clips of that and we talked
about the political and we also talked about
the medical.
Colin Powell was vaccinated.
He was 84 years old, died of COVID complications.
And I mentioned yesterday that many anti-vaxxers
would use this and point to it and say, See,
there's no point in getting vaccinated.
Ignoring, of course, that the data shows overwhelmingly
that those who die are not vaccinated.
And in addition to that, in the hours after
we published yesterday's clip, we learned
that Colin Powell was severely immunocompromised,
had Parkinson's, as well as a type of blood
cancer called multiple myeloma, which is a
big being in treatment for multiple myeloma
is a significant immuno compromising circumstance
for an individual.
But it didn't matter.
The anti-vax stuff exploded, and it wasn't
just the usual suspects, it was even Fox News
daytime reporters pushing this stuff.
The anti-vaxxers are foaming at the mouth
using Colin Powell's death while vaccinated
to attack vaccines and to attack vaccine requirements.
So we're going to go over this today.
But it's important to say again, Colin Powell
was not just a random guy who was vaccinated
and died, which can happen.
We have significant protection against severe
disease and death from the vaccines.
But with a planet of seven to eight billion
people, you're going to have some random,
seemingly healthy people who are vaccinated
and die.
That doesn't mean that we ignore the bigger
statistics.
But Colin Powell was not just a random guy.
He was not even just a random 84 year old
guy who was vaccinated and died of COVID.
He was an 84 year old immunocompromised man
who died despite being vaccinated, had cancer
and had Parkinson's, which significantly affects
your immune system.
But the anti-vaxxers want to pretend see,
the vaccine does nothing for anyone.
Anybody could die.
It's just chance.
Fox News host Will Cain went on a rant yesterday
morning, saying fully vaccinated people are
being hospitalized and dying, and it's just
we.
We can't trust anybody.
Speaker 2: He brought up COVID.
Look, this day will be a day for many things,
for remembering the man, for remembering the
leader that was lost.
It's also a day to understand the implications
on everyday Americans and in the reports he
died from complications of COVID.
The family has made a point in their post
on Facebook this morning that Colin Powell
was fully vaccinated and as Americans out
there wonder what lies ahead for them and
they search and they need truth moving forward.
We're seeing data from across the world.
We're seeing data from Europe, from the United
Kingdom.
The fully vaccinated people are being hospitalized
and fully vaccinated people are dying from
COVID.
And here we have a very high profile example
that is going to require more truth, more
truth from our government far.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, there's no lack
of truth.
The truth is you're overwhelmingly less likely
to die of COVID if you're vaccinated.
Colin Powell, he's straight up saying this
is anecdotal thinking.
He's straight up saying this case shows that
we're not getting enough truth.
This case doesn't change the truth, which
is the overwhelming majority of those who
are dying are unvaccinated, even as the country
is more and more vaccinated.
Here's another similar example this one is
from Fox and Friends playing a similar game.
Speaker 2: There will also be conversations
about the fact that he was fully vaccinated,
according to his family, and he died from
complications from COVID.
We are beginning to see statistics like this
grow in frequency.
We know that the vaccine does wane over time
and its ability to protect you from not just
transmission and infection, but from severe
complications and hospitalization and obviously
death as well.
We know that it wanes and we know that it's
beginning to spillover COVID into the vaccinated
population again.
Colin Powell in the direct.
Age demographic that suffers the most from
complications from COVID.
But I think everyone watching needs to be
aware of limitations and protections.
Speaker 1: Yeah, limitation.
You are always better off with the protection
of the vaccine.
That's the reality.
And then we'll follow up on this later.
Fox News reporter John Roberts tweeted Powles
death was evidence of the waning efficacy,
tweeting The fact that Colin Powell died from
a breakthrough COVID infection raises new
concerns about how effective vaccines are
long term.
No, it doesn't.
And he subsequently deleted this tweet.
He subsequently deleted this tweet.
As Mother Jones has been reporting.
Major news outlets ran headlines about this
without acknowledging that Colin Powell was
immunocompromised with multiple conditions
but talking about him being vaccinated.
If you're going to talk about him being vaccinated,
you've got to talk about the other side as
well.
New York Times.
Colin Powell, first black national security
adviser, died at 84 of COVID.
He was fully vaccinated, family said.
Right, but you've got to tell both sides of
that.
MSNBC Colin Powell dies from COVID complications.
Powell was fully vaccinated.
NEWSWEEK Former U.S. Secretary of State Colin
Powell dies from COVID complications was fully
vaccinated, Colin Powell said in an announcement
on social media.
He was fully vaccinated.
If you're going to do that, you should really
say fully vaccinated and severely immunocompromised.
It would be irresponsible not to.
Or skip saying both.
Skip saying both, if you want.
Here's Dr. Zeke Emanuel, discrediting the
idea that Colin Powell's death means the vaccines
aren't working, and he mentions Powell's risk
factors.
Take a look.
Speaker 3: Colin Powell had three important
risk factors for COVID.
One is his age 84.
He's at the very high end, and we know those
people are much more vulnerable.
Second, as you point out, he had cancer and
third, he's a man and men are at much higher
risk of dying, especially in his age category.
Fifty eight percent of deaths in those people
65 to 84 are male, even though they make up
a minority of that age group when it comes
to multiple myeloma.
It's a cancer of the cells, the B cells in
the immune system that produce antibodies
so they don't produce effective antibodies
and they grow and grow.
And when you treat someone for multiple myeloma,
it does suppress the immune system.
So he was immunocompromised.
Speaker 1: OK, so that's as if we needed more
medical experts telling us what has become
obvious over the year and a half of the pandemic.
So we are now going to talk separately about
specifically Tucker Carlson's dog and pony
show that he did in reaction to this because
it's particularly disastrous and particularly
weaponized